[Music]
thomas jefferson one of america's
founding fathers came up with the first
swiveling mechanism for office chairs
decades later charles darwin added small
wheels called casters to his chair to
roll around the study as he worked on
the theory of evolution
today office chairs still swivel and
roll
[Music]
the office chair has become a status
symbol executive versions have kingly
dimensions
they're extremely plush and have serious
lumbar support
[Music]
using a hydraulically powered machine
a worker bends 14 gauge steel tubing to
form the bottom cushion frame
[Music]
he joins the ends and weld steel bars to
the middle
the bars will support the mechanism for
adjusting the position of the seat
he hooks s-shaped steel springs from the
front to the back of the seat frame
these sinuous springs will eventually
provide a flexible web of suspension in
the seat
[Music]
he positions the rods laterally and
clips them to the springs for additional
stability and support
the office chair seat frame is now
complete
next a worker builds the chair's back
frame
the frame includes a spine lumbar
support armrest attachments and other
parts
he grinds burrs and other rough spots
from the steel
in the upholstery department another
worker smooths a leather hide so that it
sits evenly on the cutting table
he cuts out the patterns following
cardboard templates
as he cuts he works around the natural
flaws in the hide
making calculated decisions to minimize
waste
by cutting carefully he'll be able to
get all the leather he needs for one
chair from this large hide
that's important because color and grain
can vary from hide to hide
[Music]
using pieces from the same one will give
the chair a consistent look and texture
once all the leather pattern pieces have
been accumulated another worker cuts
foam cushioning for backing
the density of the foam in the chair
varies
he uses more rigid foam for the chair's
contoured cushioning so it will hold its
shape
[Music]
another worker selects softer foam for
the part of the chair that the
occupant's back will rest against
[Music]
he cut slits into this softer back
padding
this creates channels that will
ultimately become a design feature
[Music]
using chalk he draws lines onto the
corresponding leather
that match up with the slits in the foam
a worker aligns the chalk lines in the
leather with the slits
and puckers the leather as he sews the
backing to it
this forms a rib pattern in the upper
half of the chair upholstery
[Music]
he stitches the padding flat to many of
the other pattern pieces
this particular part is a side panel for
the back of the chair
returning to the upholstery with the
ribbing now he sews contoured casings to
each side
[Music]
to complete the back of the chair
workers add a chipboard panel and encase
the structure with foam then cover it
with the leather upholstery
once the chair seat has been upholstered
an employee installs a plastic cover to
enclose the back
he screws a sliding plate to the base
this mechanism will work in conjunction
with the plate to slide the seat forward
and backward depending on leg room needs
it also has features for adjusting the
tilt and height of the seat
the hydraulic cylinder for adjusting the
seat height is next
the cylinder also doubles as the chair
stem and it swivels to allow the seat to
rotate 360 degrees
he attaches the aluminum base to the
cylinder
[Music]
he snaps the casters into slots in the
aluminum base
[Music]
he equips the back of the office chair
with an automobile style headrest
the prongs fit into the brackets in the
chair frame
finally he locks the armrests into the
frame
[Music]
this office chair is now ready to make
someone's desk job a lot more
comfortable
[Music]